thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we are in the midst of another
Monumental episode we have Colleen
Reinhart with us oh hello we also have
Nick Dunn Steve Greener Anthony Lee and
Joe jitsukawa
today goes back we are discussing for
those of you who are married and those
of you who are not
is divorce out of the question
that's what I think everybody says but
then they get divorced because they suck
at marriage
until his marriage thinking I'm gonna
divorce one day no one thinks that no
one thinks that you sure I don't think
so I don't think people go into the
marriage going like you know I can't
wait till we get divorced yesterday I
think some people have it as a a thing
like they they think it's in the back of
their mind yeah I've heard people say
that for Solo or they're just just in
them we're so [ __ ] dope like but
that's the exception right everyone
thinks that they're different from
everybody else we're special we got it
figured out they don't and then the
problems start happening Life Starts
happening they can't cooperate they
start arguing all these issues and then
they get divorced so does that mean that
in in the uh in your marriage
every problem that could possibly happen
you can visualize working through it no
you can solve it with a divorce easy
that's the easy way to do it okay
no look there's something whack about
saying divorces out of the question
because that means the partner could
just kick it well you don't have to
[ __ ] work hard anymore and you could
just be like a couch potato video game
guy or whatever and like I mean nothing
but you're engaged with your partner
sometimes too and so like if you're just
gonna kick it and just chill in your
relationship and let it stagnate divorce
should absolutely be a stop Gap there
and be like something that you could you
could resort to to keep your partner
engaged I don't divorce I don't believe
in divorce I just I just believe in
cheating that's that's how you do it so
to be honest right when if I were to say
divorce is out of the question in my
head I'm just not even making it an
option because I might use it as a
cop-out
okay interesting yeah you don't trust
yourself you mean like this is a little
off no because like I think when you are
uh pushed to your limits instead of
working things out like you might use it
as a as a as a get out of jail oh I know
you mean yeah but then to win an
argument you just needed to like no you
just needed to work [ __ ] out you know
like so like for example there's some
non-negotiables like maybe uh depending
on the couple cheating might be one
sneaking fine like doing shady [ __ ]
right like where you're just like oh man
you really [ __ ] it up here
cheating is the one I think cheating is
like that could be but there's some
people that stay together and there's
some like that are like
I don't know it just depends on each
couple what's what their non-negotiables
are right I think those obvious ones
like abuse you know like if I'm getting
my ass beat every day I gotta get out of
that situation right
but if it's something else like ah we
just keep fighting over the toilet seat
and I think it's time to get a divorce
like that kind of [ __ ] I think that's
the kind of [ __ ] that I'm like it does I
don't want to I don't want to use that
as an option for that and when people do
they just divorce because they just
[ __ ] can't work out their [ __ ]
yeah I don't know
sometimes people
um get pressured by their Community to
get married too soon
you know what I mean like or even like
church groups you know religiously right
it's like uh there's this kind of stigma
so sometimes people in their uh like
I've seen this happen many times uh in
their like religious communities they'll
just feel that pressure so they'll get
married but they were young and then
like four years later it's like that
[ __ ] was not gonna work out and divorce
is actually like a Saving Grace for them
yeah you know what I mean so I think uh
in those situations the fact that it
exists is can be healthy I guess
I've had friends
um that
divorces out of the question 100 they've
had
infidelity they've had
[ __ ] molestation they still don't
divorce I've had uh family members that
have gone through abuse
because in families that religion is the
top spot divorce is out of the question
honestly it's usually that
because I know people who married
their first choice
because they just wanted to get out of
the house and that was the only way and
then obviously you're in your early 20s
like 20 21 22 you don't make the best of
decisions if you didn't have much
experience about the outside world and
then they're splitting up in their 40s
and 50s with kids because they they
realize oh I wasn't even with the person
I wanted to be I used them as an escape
right yeah that's that's the reason I
was asking because I've I've have I've
grown up around divorce being out of the
question I've grown up around it like
almost my entire I have a [ __ ]
gigantic family maybe like two people
have been divorced and it's still
kind of like oh that's too bad you guys
didn't do like what we were planning to
do and that's not I get divorced it's
like it's more important to not get
divorced than it is to have a good
marriage for you were you rooting for
them to divorce you're like Yeah The
Modern Age I'm like yeah if you're being
[ __ ] abused get the [ __ ] out yeah but
there's a lot of selfishness with
families too where say there's like a
routine like um your family goes to this
house for Christmas but then those
people get divorced and then the
families are like well that ruins you
know there's so much [ __ ] that's like
yeah it doesn't really matter it doesn't
[ __ ] such a big deal from people yeah
or like the shame of it right because a
lot of people see like divorce as like
failure
you know right like not you because you
and this couple didn't work out you just
have to break up and it's like
shame on the rest of the family I know
there's a lot of that stuff there that's
fair to say because I think like when
when religion is the base of many things
it kind of Logics out the window for
most things and I think marriage is one
of those things that gets affected by
that but
um I always thought like I grew up
saying that as weird as it sounds to be
like it's worse out of the question I
grew up always going dead divorce is
another question for me because I can't
uh I really can't picture like uh maybe
I'll still do it someday who knows but
then like my whole life it's been like a
thing that hey if you if you think you
could ever get divorced then you don't
deserve to get married it's like a weird
[ __ ] indoctrinated like thing well
there's a stigma about failure too it's
like okay so I failed in my marriage say
and like a divorce would be that and
it's like that's bad but like bro
failure has taught me so much [ __ ] in
life and teaches people it's the
greatest instructor I think so like the
idea that like you gotta sit there and
be stigmatized be stigmatized because
you had a failed marriage there's a
whack it's like I think you'll do better
next time like you you'll maybe stick up
for yourself going in more or look for
things more going in than you did last
time yeah I think it's imperative for
growth I pushed my mom to file divorce
papers so when my dad left when I was 13
14
um they never actually got a divorce so
they were still technically married and
then
um we both had carried his last name and
I made the first move when I was 16 or
17 to get the tattoo of my grandma's
last name
because I wanted to change it and then
um I think I got a lawyer
my mom's friend he helped me file to
change my last name legally and then I
said you need just like even if it's
easier to to file taxes like married
status you'll probably benefit much more
because I'm a dependent and you're a
single mother so go ahead and do that
and also collect because he hasn't been
sending us any money and then like he
was complaining like you're trying to
[ __ ] believe me dry [ __ ] and he was
like only sending couple hundred like we
just told him to send a couple hundred
bucks a month to pay for phone bill
right yeah and just that's it and he's
like 200 bucks a month you [ __ ] [ __ ]
trying to Bleed Me [ __ ] drive
right you [ __ ] gold digging [ __ ]
it's crazy and then and then
how much sold Yeah so basically I my mom
didn't want to do it for the same
reasons she's not even a part of the
church yeah she just thought that
divorce was like a sin and all this and
I'm like [ __ ] that when not a part of
the church [ __ ] those people like [ __ ]
everybody just do what you got to do and
then so after that
um she actually filed for those papers
she'll she got you know all that stuff
and then she didn't even ask for
anything but like yeah like a couple
hundred bucks a month which he stopped
paying after like a year but like it's
like all those things right I'm like
divorce is not
a bad thing if you're in a [ __ ] up
situation no it's a good thing because I
rooted for that and then we felt so much
more liberated after that yeah yeah what
about the stigma of
people who or like it's like a thing I
grew up hearing it all the time I don't
know if it's as common now but when
people go oh your parents got a divorce
that means you're more likely to get a
divorce that is the thing yeah I mean
it's statistically true and I can just
from my own experience I can see why is
it is it fair
I mean it's it's not nice to hear but
that's the same thing as saying oh like
you got beat as a kid you are more
likely to probably discipline your
children the same way yeah it's not that
you want to hear that but I understand
that stat maybe it's more mentally like
an option to you than for somebody who
hasn't been through that or lived
through it or if you've seen your
parents divorced because you saw the
tragedy and then you saw the greatness
afterwards and then you see that same
tragedy in your own situation and
recognize that there's greatness on the
other side that makes sense it's all
application right it's just a wild thing
to say to somebody
oh shoot your parents got divorced oh
[ __ ] you're next huh yeah hey anything
and when you when you think about like I
remembered when I was a uh when I was a
kid the first friend I had whose family
is going through divorce it was like
devastating to the whole school like we
were just and the church I went to
church and school with this kid and we
were best friends and we were in first
grade and like we were six years old and
he was struggling to tell me like hey I
I want to talk to you about something at
six six years old we were six and then I
was like what's going on [ __ ] adult
conversation and he was sitting like
this we were just like we were just
sitting together and he just goes
um it's about my parents
and then I was like I had no clue like
what oh my god did they die and he's
just like
yeah maybe maybe ask your mom because I
don't know how to talk about it and it
was like the saddest [ __ ] and then I
asked my mom like hey uh you know
so-and-so's parents uh there's something
going on and my mom was like okay uh I
think we need to teach you now that
sometimes you know parents don't always
stay together and it was the craziest
thing to learn and then um I don't know
so much that this dude had uh
I don't know if that really played into
the likelihood of his future but he he
did have a little bit of a problem with
marriage later in life Tim did you keep
telling him yeah
I said bam and then it compounds from
there like if you get a divorce and then
you get another divorce you're you're
three times more likely to get another
division yeah yeah yeah yeah
it just keeps on growing 10xing dude
it's like an unpaid parking ticket
pounds that's what made me uh realize
that in my personal opinion I didn't
think it was so much that oh his parents
got divorced so now he was likely to get
a divorce I think it all rides on the
understanding you leave the kid with and
I don't think they did the best job
I think being six years old and hearing
the way we were both trying to like
suddenly have to be adults about it it's
like that's probably not the best way he
had no clue like really how to say it
what to do what to you know he felt like
it was his fault like it's all the
classic things it's all the classic [ __ ]
it's like self-blame like all this worth
you know and then and I saw his his
confidence like I went I went to school
with him for nine years straight
kindergarten to eighth grade and I I
remembered like
the ups and downs like he had and I was
like [ __ ] man like that's probably more
important than whether or not someone
got divorced you know dude you're the
most observant six-year-old I've ever
heard about seriously I was I was
probably like dude who you guys would
think would win Donatello or splinter
but that's what we were trying to talk
about but that's the sad thing is this
guy was killed the Bible yeah you learn
a new word it's always like what if
Raphael and Donatello get a divorce
I'm like okay Casey Jones has to fight
Shredder but he doesn't have his hockey
stick and then all of my friends like
whoa
holy [ __ ] I think that's the best part
with like growing up with the same
friends for so long is that interactions
that you had at six you're talking about
them at seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve so the story continues you know
like he remembers distinctly to this day
having that talk with me and it's still
sad you know did you go to the same
school back then yeah I went to
Bellflower uh oh okay okay step into
Union School from kindergarten to eighth
grade and then you swapped over to my
school same like 16 friends all all nine
years who's stronger Superman or Hulk
Superman right yeah for sure Superman
whole price
yeah but Superman's he's not far off
he's right there
he's too simpy dude I can kind of see
his wife cheating on him with Batman
with a dark knight dude
Superman
oh [ __ ] it's getting soft on us dude for
everybody here because I'm a team member
you know and by the way Shredder would
win uh I think so too I think that's not
bad sure yeah yeah when you talk about
Casey Jones
keep up with the conversation right
Shredder versus Superman Ryan still
think about this stupid divorce
conversation
anymore what's next next I do believe
like why that stat also is true about
the whole divorce thing right is couples
that are more likely to divorce it's
because they don't have conflict
resolution so that couple that ended up
getting divorced you grow up watching
the lack of conflict resolution whereas
some marriages I mean obviously some of
them just are really good at bearing
issues and they don't stick with any of
that [ __ ] stop it [ __ ] how did
you know I saw him talking about Captain
Planet dude
so like some couples right they or or
like in in their um they're like uh
they're like they should get divorced
but they bury all of their issues so
that's a whole different set of problems
that you can't objectively identify so
they might get into another marriage
copying mommy and daddy
but an abusive relationship like your
family they never get divorced and then
statistically you think that's a
successful marriage when it's not right
right right right that's the danger that
I was talking about it's like oh the
preservation of one's reputation yeah
and the willingness to like constantly
come home to something that shouldn't be
exactly holy [ __ ] dude
yeah that's the problem with having an
outside motivator like uh whether it's
you're standing in a community or
religion as a whole like religion I
think in that sense kind of could be a
good or bad thing because religion might
make you a better person but also you're
confined to these specific rules where
it's like hey in the Bible it says a
woman is a man's property so which is
true yeah I said to my wife one more
time you're made out of my ribs [ __ ]
yeah I know ladies love that because
it's hot I love that yeah
that's probably why they came up with
like arranged marriage and all this [ __ ]
because they're like man look at these
stupid ass kids they can't choose their
own partner so then you choose someone
for them or like they have all these
different systems that humans try to uh
prevent as the least problems for the
future yeah but it's the parents who are
setting up those arranged marriages and
they're the ones that raise that child
to be stupid so who's really stupid yeah
right that's true and I feel like they
is they use uh like kids to barter for
marriage for like building relationships
and business like I think that that was
like how it started before and I think
we should keep continuing to do that to
this day every day I think when you wrap
a kid up in that type of [ __ ] whether or
not the kid gets divorced as well is
probably the least of your behavioral
concerns yeah was it you who's telling
me about like there's a pet there's like
a court
um thing about a like two people getting
divorced there's a dog involved and then
they're like let the dog pick and they
like let the dog go in court
wait is that real yeah yeah I told you
that yeah that's like that Tick Tock
video where they [ __ ] both run this
way and the dog chases one or the other
dog like runs up to the judge yeah who
knows get me out of here Landers and
they're calling Maggie yeah yeah yeah
what's the stat Now isn't it over 50
percent of marriages end up in divorce
yeah I think the stats is uh women
initiate
I've heard of that so women were more
likely to leave relationships than men
yeah do we know
um what like the leading cause for that
is complacency I bet or is it like is it
it's like changes but it's because men
are more likely to cheat like what's the
real cause I know that infidelity at
least the last time I looked wasn't
number one I know we talked about this
yesterday chores yeah chores I thought
it was financing yeah I think women are
in positions where they don't
necessarily feel like
the man is adding as much value to the
relationship so they're more inclined to
leave
um like they make their own money now
they actually make more money than than
some men do so absolutely less they
don't have to lean on them as much you
don't have to be as codependent in their
relationship so they don't put up with
the you know
sorry what did you say oh they just met
a new guy that's richer
sure that could be another variable I
wish I could meet a new guy that's
richer speaking of richer Iron Man or
Batman Iron Man Iron Man all the way
yeah he's way richer than Bruce Wayne
because the repulsers probably huh price
is all the other Tech Iron Man is
self-made Bruce Wayne is a [ __ ] rich
boy it's actually lower I heard it's
been getting lower it's actually it's
actually the pandemic worked for us it's
actually between 40 and 50 now it
actually went down hey congrats I think
maybe less people are marrying could be
because at least that's what I'm
recognizing too is like people are
waiting till later on in age to marry
and people just don't marry at all it
says be more intentional with who they
choose to marry so they wait longer yeah
they're so [ __ ] expensive to get
divorced and say oh [ __ ] yeah that's
also true and some people just separate
without ever filing yeah uh the ages
between 28 32 so far statistically have
the most successful marriages wait 28 to
32 8-32 yeah if they stay around that
age like they never age no no like
if they could last through that age then
their marriage is got married at the age
of either 28 29 39 132 those are the
highest rate of rate of Stay Together
yeah and then the leading cause so far
uh at this point is still
basically incompatibility where it's
like that gray like yeah irreconcilable
differences yeah have you guys seen that
one of them was in-laws in-laws
right here finances huh not number one
but I'm sure Finance is probably in-laws
being pains in the asses or oh just over
involving themselves in your relay uh
that causes Dynamics with the couple too
because it's like oh you're not
supporting me this you're not doing that
that's one thing my mom said is that
when you get married to someone you're
not marrying her you're marrying her
family so watch out for her family yeah
yeah infidelity is up there
um distance
uh domestic violence substance that
should be a big one ooh substance drugs
and violence get the hell out of there
lack of shared interests yeah oh really
it's like you never go kayaking with me
yeah kayaking's here yeah and then you
get a divorce offer no kayaking time
yeah
[Music]
foreign